This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。“绝对真人。”2%。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO. percent。欢迎收听 Look Back at it 播客。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代一样。84 年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段孕事似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。互联网侦探们出动了大批人马，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化与转折，以及它们的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. If nothing else, our 20s are this kind of beautiful time of transformation and
为了我们的心理健康。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎新老听众再次回到播客，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析我们二十岁的心理。如果说二十岁有什么特点的话，那就是这是一段美好的蜕变时期，并且
reinvention. That is a universal truth, a universal statement for me that each of us, no matter what we're going through, what we're struggling with, what we do or don't achieve, we will have to rediscover time and time again who we are. And we also have to rediscover how far off that is from who we want to be probably hundreds of times during this period of emerging adulthood. We spend so much of childhood and also our teenage years being the person that others want us to be, or rebelling against this version entirely to carve out what we think is our own space. And I think our 20s is when we start to find balance and we really get the chance to do that all over again and independently.
重塑自我。这是一个普遍真理，对我而言是一个普遍的陈述：我们每个人，无论正在经历什么，正在为什么苦恼，无论我们取得了什么成就还是毫无所获，在这个步入成年初期的阶段，我们都不得不在几百次的时间里，重新去发现自己究竟是谁。而且我们很可能还得无数次地去重新审视：现在的自己，和我们想要成为的人之间，究竟还有多大的差距。我们在童年乃至青少年的大部分时间里，都在努力扮演别人希望我们成为的人，或者彻底叛逆于这种模式，以此来开辟出我们认为属于自己的空间。而我认为，二十岁正是我们开始寻找平衡，并且真正有机会以独立的方式重新经历这一切的时期。
And we approach, you know, self-discovery with a new maturity and a new sense of truth. things about us become a lot more clear. And what we're likely to experience is a bit of a metamorphosis and a shedding of the old into the new. This is definitely a rite of passage. And sometimes it's deeply uncomfortable. But when you get to the point of not really enjoying your life, not liking who you are, not knowing what you stand for, what your dreams are, who you even want to be,
而且我们开始以一种新的成熟度和对真相的新理解来探索自我。关于我们的事情变得越来越清晰。我们很可能会经历某种程度的蜕变，褪去旧我，迎来新我。这绝对是一场成人的仪式。有时这会让人感到极度不适。但当你开始真正厌倦生活、不喜欢现在的自己、不知道自己坚信什么、不知道梦想是什么、甚至不知道自己究竟想成为什么样的人时，
You are really, I think, called to a place of reinvention. And that is what I want to talk about today. How can we reinvent and rediscover ourselves in our 20s when things start to feel stagnant or off? Or we start to feel a sense of disconnection between who we are right now and who we really want to be? How do we kind of shake things up? How do we find our path? How do we have that refresh where we fall back in love with our lives through our old actions? well, we are going to talk through five tips that you can work through either step by step
我想，你其实是被命运召唤到了一个需要重塑自我的境地。而这正是我今天想要探讨的话题。当生活开始显得停滞不前或有些不对劲时，我们如何在二十岁时重塑和重新发现自我？或者当我们开始感到现在的自己与真正想成为的自己之间出现脱节时？我们该如何打破现状？如何找到我们的道路？如何通过那些陈旧的行为，迎来一次重新深爱生活的“焕新”之旅呢？嗯，我们将探讨五个你可以付诸实践的建议，你可以循序渐进地执行，
or you can kind of choose one or the other for reinvention during this decade. This includes some methods for visualizing your next chapter and how to use psychology to really motivate yourself to get there, how to use psychology to motivate a sense of confidence. Also how we can use that discomfort, use the boredom, the isolation, the stagnation, the stagnation, the stagnation, the uncertainty in our favor, rather than fighting against it. How can we actually take all of those things that are making us crave reinvention and help us get there rather than kind of, I don't know, burden us? We are also going to discuss the power of risk and this construct called the timeline for change
或者你也可以选择其中一个或几个方法，在这个十年里重塑自我。这包括一些可视化你下一篇章的方法，以及如何利用心理学真正激励自己到达目标，如何利用心理学来激发自信心。还有我们如何将这种不适感、无聊感、孤立感、停滞感、不确定性为我们所用，而不是与之对抗。我们如何才能真正利用所有这些让我们渴望重塑自我的因素来帮助我们实现目标，而不是让它们成为我们的负担？我们还将讨论风险的力量以及一个叫做“改变时间线”的概念，
and how to shift from very anxious, what if thinking, to a what else or so what mentality, which is honestly one of my favorite ways to think about this. One of my favorite ideas in this space is that switch, that mental and cognitive switch from seeing things in a disaster scenario lens or from a disaster scenario lens to an abundant lens from an abundant position of excess and authenticity and growth. growth. I've got to say this is one of my favorite episodes that I've done as of recent because it just combines all my favorite like nuggets of advice and theories into one package. And truly it really represents so much of my philosophy towards this period in our lives. You know, our 20s are for
以及如何从非常焦虑的“万一……”思维转变为“管他呢”或“大不了……”的心态，老实说，这是我最喜欢看待这个问题的方式之一。在这个领域，我最喜欢的理念之一就是这种转变，这种心理和认知上的转变：从灾难情境的视角转变为丰盛视角，从一种充满丰盛感、真实感和成长的立场出发。我必须说，这是我近期做过最喜欢的节目之一，因为它把我所有最喜欢的建议和理论精华完美地结合在了一个包裹里。而且它确实很好地代表了我对人生这一阶段的大部分哲学思考。你知道，二十岁是用来
exploration. They are for reinvention, rebuilding, transformation more so than any other time. So I really want us to be able to unlock that for ourselves, even if it's through small steps, even if it's not as drastic as you're picturing. Also, I guess whenever I get the opportunity to talk about risk and our approach to uncertainty, that is like a favorite topic of mine, because it's something that I deeply, deeply think is important that we stop seeing risk is scary and we start seeing risk as investment. It really falls into this overall concept and topic of reinvention. So I am very excited to talk about this. I'm enthused. I'm invigorated. So I think without further ado, let us get into the five ways that we can reinvent ourselves in our 20s.
探索的。比起其他任何时期，这一时期更适合用来重塑自我、重建生活和实现蜕变。所以我真的很希望我们能为自己开启这种可能，哪怕只是通过一小步，哪怕不如你想象中那么天翻地覆。另外，我想每当我获得机会去谈论风险以及我们面对不确定性的态度时，这都是我最喜欢的话题，因为我深深地、深深地认为，很重要的一点是，我们必须停止将风险视为可怕的事物，转而将风险视为投资。这确实契合了重塑自我这一整体概念和主题。所以我非常高兴能聊聊这个话题。我很热情，充满活力。所以我想事不宜迟，让我们切入在二十岁重塑自我的五种方法。
Reinventing yourself, changing your life. I think it really has to begin with identifying what it is about your current circumstances, your day to day, your habits that are dissatisfying. to you? What is the main feeling that you have towards your life at the moment that is giving you this itch to change things up that is making you restless? There are a few big ones that I think are specifically noteworthy in our 20s. The first one is boredom, boredom feeling like not much is happening in your life, nothing exciting is happening, nothing is changing, you're not changing, the things that really elevate our day-to-day experiences, like, adventure, like excitement, like spontaneity. It's just not there. It's this sense of just like
重塑自我，改变生活。我认为它真的必须从识别现状、日常生活以及那些让你感到不满意的习惯开始。你目前对生活的主要感觉是什么，是什么让你产生了改变现状的冲动，是什么让你感到坐立不安？我认为有几个主要的感觉在我们的二十岁特别值得注意。第一个是无聊，无聊的感觉就像你的生活中没有发生什么事，没有什么激动人心的事发生，没有什么在改变，你没有在改变，那些真正提升我们日常体验的事物，比如冒险、比如兴奋、比如随性。这些统统没有。这正是一种平庸的感觉。
plainness. Bortem is the first one. Then we have stagnation and this is very similar to boredom, but it's more so centered on a sense that you've kind of become complacent in some domain of your life, even if you're still doing fun things. This is particularly to do with our careers or to do with some larger goal, finding that, you know, you're really not working towards something the way that you anticipated that you would be or the way that you have in the past, feeling very stuck. Then we have isolation, lacking connection, lacking community, feeling lonely and maybe with that, you know, some phomo that you're missing out on the experiences that others seem to be having during this time. And then the final feeling that I think also makes us quite itchy for change
无聊是第一种。然后是停滞，这和无聊非常相似，但它更多地集中在一种感觉上：你在生活的某个领域变得自满，即使你仍在做有趣的事情。这尤其与我们的职业生涯或某个更宏大的目标有关，你会发现，你知道，你并没有像预期中那样或者像过去那样为某个目标而努力，从而感到非常卡壳。接下来是孤立，缺乏联系，缺乏社群，感到孤独，或许伴随着某种“错失恐惧症”（FOMO），觉得别人在这个时期都在经历各种丰富的生活，而你却错过了。然后最后一种我认为同样让我们迫切渴望改变的感觉，
is just a general discomfort, a feeling that's probably very similar to anxiety, that something about your life just isn't quite right. You don't seem to fit in your current circumstances anymore. You know, you have these habits, these friends, these situations, that your body is very instinctually telling you, this is not what we want. We're not comfortable here. We're not happy here.
就是一种普遍的不适感，这种感觉可能非常类似于焦虑，即你的生活中有某种东西就是不太对劲。你似乎再也无法适应目前的处境了。你知道，你拥有这些习惯、这些朋友、这些处境，而你的身体正在非常本能地告诉你：这不是我们想要的。我们在这里并不舒服。我们在这里并不快乐。
And often it does that through heightened sensitivity, being very nervous, repetitive thoughts that are again and again bringing you back to some issue that you're having, a sense of detachment between who you know you can be and who you are now. So these feelings, boredom, stagnation, isolation and discomfort, they tell us something very useful, even though it's unpleasant. And what they're telling us is that we need to change, we need to shift, we need to be doing something different and hopefully sooner rather than later. The reason that I say sooner rather than later is because if you don't do something not instantly but pretty soon, the alternative is that we begin to get quite comfortable with the
通常它会通过高度的敏感、极度的紧张、重复的思维来表现出来，这些思维不断将你拉回你正在遇到的某个问题，拉回那种“你知道自己可以成为什么样的人”与“现在的你”之间的疏离感。所以这些感觉——无聊、停滞、孤立和不适——它们告诉了我们一些非常有用但在当时并不愉快的信息。它们在告诉我们，我们需要改变，我们需要转型，我们需要做一些不同的事情，最好是趁早，而不是为时已晚。我之所以说“趁早，而不是为时晚”，是因为如果你不采取行动——不是立刻，但也要相当快——那么另一个选择就是我们开始对这种不适感习以为常。
discomfort. We get comfortable with being bored, with being lonely, with being stuck, and we think that that's normal. In psychology, this process is actually called habituation. And it refers to our tendency to get more and more used to something that used to frustrate us or bother us as time goes on. You know, I think about, so I, for example, I actually live under like a plane line. What's it called? Like a flight path, right? And when I first moved into this house, like the sound of planes going overhead was so, would just bother me so much. It was all I could think about. But the longer that I've lived here, I don't even notice it anymore. Like, I'm sure that. about five planes have probably flown over the skies above my house in the time that I've been
我们习惯了无聊，习惯了孤独，习惯了卡壳，并且我们认为这是正常的。在心理学中，这个过程实际上被称为“习惯化”。它指的是随着时间推移，我们对那些曾经让我们沮丧或困扰的事情变得越来越习惯的倾向。你知道，我想到了，比如我，我其实住在飞机航线下面。这叫什么？就像是一条飞行航线，对吧？当我刚搬进这栋房子时，飞机从头顶飞过的声音简直太烦人了，让我极其困扰。满脑子都是这个。但住的时间越久，我甚至都注意不到它了。就像，我敢肯定，自我开始录制这期节目以来，大概已经有五架飞机从我家上空飞过了，但我已经习惯了。而当我们对本不该习惯的事物习以为常时，发生的也是同样的事情。你不应该对生活中的无聊、孤立或停滞感到习惯。我们只有很短的窗口期来阻止这种习惯化的发生并采取行动。否则，事情确实会变得越来越难。就像戒掉一个坏习惯一样。我们想要探讨的是，如果我们将这些情绪状态完全颠覆，生活会是什么样子。所以当我们感到无聊时，我们承诺去追求刺激；当我们感到停滞时，我们承诺去追求成长；在孤立时追求连接；在不适时追求平静与边界。所以我希望你做的
recording this but I've become habituated and that is the same thing that happens when we get comfortable with something that we should not be comfortable with. You should not be comfortable with being born in your life or being isolated or being stagnant and we have a really small window to stop that habituation from happening and to act. Otherwise, it does get harder and harder. It's like breaking a bad habit. What we want to explore is what life would look like. If we flipped those emotional states to be the complete opposite. So when we felt bored, we made a commitment to pursue excitement. When we felt stagnant, we made a commitment to pursue growth, to pursue connection over isolation, to pursue peace and boundaries over discomfort. So what I want from you
是，首先去注意是什么驱使你想要重塑或刷新生活，然后制定一个接下来 30 天的计划，去做所有与最初那种感觉截然相反的事情。趁着你依然被这种不适感所激励，我们要彻底颠覆你的生活。例如，如果你现在对生活感到无比无聊，我希望你在便签应用上或在一张纸上列出一系列你一直想在你的城市或小镇做但却没有做过的活动。并且我希望你承诺每两天或每三天去做一件。
is to really, to begin with, notice what is driving you to want to reinvent or refresh your life and then make a plan for the next 30 days to do all the things that feel the exact opposite to that initial feeling. We're going to really shake up your life whilst you're still feeling motivated by the discomfort. For example, if you are just feeling so bored with your life right now, I want you to make a list in your notes up or on a sheet of paper to put on your fridge of a series of activities that you've always wanted to do in your city or your town that you haven't. And I want you to be committed to doing one every two days, every three days.
或者如果有什么课程、你一直想追求的爱好，那就报名一个需要你周复一周去上课的为期六周的课程。办一张新的健身卡，做点不一样的事情。新奇的体验会真真切切地给人一种“我们的生活时间变多了”的印象。2016 年有一项关于此的研究变得相当知名，研究发现，随着年龄增长，时间确实似乎过得更快了。并不是因为时间真的过得更快了，而是因为我们学习的东西变少了，我们接触到的新事物变少了。
Or if there is a class, a hobby you've always wanted to pursue, sign up for a six-week course that you have to go to week after a week. get a new gym membership, just do something different. Novel experiences quite literally give the impression of creating more time in our lives. And there's a 2016 study around this that has become quite well known that found that the older we get, time does seem to actually pass quicker. Not because it's actually going any faster, but because we are learning less. we are exposed to fewer new things.
我们对已知的事物变得越来越习以为常。但真正能创造出“时间变多”这种心理体验的，是新奇感和新鲜事物。而这正是我们需要重新引入的，好把我们从通往冷漠和单调的道路上拉回来。所以把兴奋感重新注入你的生活，因为这是一个你可以做出的选择。你知道，这是你可以靠自己改变的事情，以此来重塑你对自己处境的感受。如果你感到停滞不前，情况也是如此。找出它发生在哪一个领域，并为你自己列出一系列你知道能帮打破这种状态的事情。如果它与工作有关——我发现通常都是这样，或者与职业有关——我希望你改变你的日常。
We become more accustomed to what we already know. But what actually creates the mental experience of more time is novelty and newness. And that is what we need to reintroduce to kind of pull us out of the path towards indifference and monotony. So put the excitement back in your life because that is a choice for you. You know, that is something that you can change on your own to reinvent how you feel about your circumstances. The same goes for if you're feeling stagnant, you know, identify what area that's in and make yourself a list of a series of things that you know would help you break out of that. If it's work related, which I find it often is or career related, I want you to change your routine.
我希望你每天花 30 分钟申请新工作，而不是刷手机。我希望你去建立人脉。我希望你主动去接触那些你在网上钦佩的人，发出那些求职邮件，这样当你上床睡觉时，你就会有一种自己做成了某件事的感觉。去报名参加社交活动。思考一下接下来你可以做什么。我认为重塑自我完全关乎行动，关乎选择你想要前进的方向并真正去追求它。一旦你尝试将拨盘从无聊、停滞或其他任何状态向相反方向拨动之后，就是时候真正开始可视化你的下一个时代、这个全新的自己会是谁、以及这个全新版本的你会如何行动了。
I want you to spend 30 minutes a day applying for new jobs instead of scrolling. I want you to be networking. I want you to be, you know, reaching out to people that you admire are online, shooting off those emails, so that when you go to bed, you have a sense that you've done something. You know, sign up for the networking event. Contemplate what you could do next. I think reinvention is all about movement and picking the direction you want to go in and actually pursuing it. Once you've kind of tested sliding the dial to your boredom, your stagnation, whatever it is in the opposite direction, it's time to really begin to visualize your needs. next era and who this new version of you will be, but also how this new version of you will act.
你知道，在你最狂野的幻想中，在你最宏大、最庞大的梦想里，真实的自我究竟是谁？回望镜中的那个角色是谁？如果你仍然不确定那是谁，甚至不知道该如何可视化这个版本的自己，我有一些问题可以真正帮助你将这个人的元素呈现出来。那么，有哪些梦想是你记事起就一直怀揣却又一再搁置的？究竟是什么真正让你兴奋？你可以谈论几个小时的话题是什么？五年后，你理想中的平均一天生活会是什么样子的？它与现在有什么不同？你准备好关闭生活中的哪个篇章了，是什么在阻碍你关闭这个篇章，又是什么在阻碍你把一切抛诸脑后去成为最真实的自己？你对这些问题的回答应该真正开始指引你走向生活的下一个时代。你知道，如果你回过头来看，我想，如果我们回顾过去人生故事中的片段，你会在事后真正看到这些奇怪的线条或时期被刻在你的记忆中。你会开始注意到，生活并不是一长串单一事件的序列——我想它确实是，但实际上，它是一系列不同的季节和时期，在这些时期里，你有着不同的目标、也许不同的朋友、不同的雄心壮志、不同的审美风格，甚至可能住在不同的地方，
You know, in your wildest fantasies, your greatest, largest dreams, who is your authentic self? Who is the character staring back at you? If you still are unsure about who that is, how to even visualize this version of yourself, I have some questions to really help you bring elements of this person forward. So what are some of the dreams that you've had for as long as you can remember that you've always put off? What truly excites you? What could you talk about for hours? In five years time, what would your ideal but average day in your life look like? And how is that different from now? What chapter of your life are you ready to close and what is holding you back from closing that
你的日常也是不一样的。我们每个人都有这些不同的时代或生活篇章，它们代表了我们是谁以及我们当时正在经历什么。而你的这个下一个时代将是一个真实的时代。这将是一个你将所有那些根深蒂固的梦想、价值观和目标引导出来，并在接下来六个月到一年里优先考虑它们的时代。这就是你如何将自己带入这个新篇章并重塑自我。我们可以掌握决定一个新季节何时为我们开启的主动权，无论外界正在发生什么。而这真正始于：在它甚至尚未显现之前，你就能够看到、感受到、触摸到、听到并体验到这个新时代对你而言代表着什么。在某种程度上，你已经做到了这一点，通过聚焦于我们之前讨论过的那些问题，你确实已经有了一个概念。但随后你必须把它从脑海中搬出来，转化为某种物理形式，无论是通过行动还是通过类似视觉化的方式。所以人们做到这一点的一些方法就像是情绪板（愿景板），你知道，花一个下午的时间，真正把这下一个篇章对你来说是什么样子的内容写在纸上或海报上，你知道，附上你要去的目的地的照片、成就、
chapter or what is holding you back from putting everything behind the truest version of yourself. Your answers to these questions should really begin to direct you to what this next error of your life is going to bring. You know, if you were to look back, I think, and if we were to look back at past parts of our life story, you start to really see in hindsight these strange lines or periods that are carved into your memories. You begin to notice that life isn't one long sequence of events and I guess it is, but actually it's a series of seasons and a series of periods within which you've had different goals, maybe different friends, different ambitions, different, you know, sense of style, maybe you've even lived in a different place,
你将看到的自然风光、你将拥有的清晨、让你放松的爱好。你需要对你真正在瞄准的目标有一个概念。而视觉化在心理学上具有极大的力量。最近有一项研究表明，大约四分之一的成功企业家使用愿景板或类似的过程来为自己规划改变。还有一项 2019 年的研究也表明，尽管有时我们觉得愿景板挺傻的，但实际上并非如此，它们几乎能将个人实现预期结果所需必要行动的信心水平提高一倍，
your routine was different. We each have these different errors or chapters of our lives that represent who we were and what we were going through at that time. And this next error for you is going to be one of authenticity. It's going to be one where you're going to channel all of those deeply rooted dreams and values and goals and actually to spend the next six months to a year prioritizing them. That is how you're going to bring yourself into this next chapter and reinvent yourself. we can be in the business of deciding when a new season begins for us, regardless of what is happening externally. And that really starts with being able to see, feel, touch, hear, experience
并且它能促使人们去寻找支持性的资源，它能让“他们想成为什么样的人”、“他们正在朝着什么目标努力”这幅愿景非常清晰地留在他们脑海的最前沿，因为生活充满了干扰，有很多事情把我们拉向这个方向、那个方向。你知道，你很忙，你知道，有来自别人的期待，有需要担心的钱，有需要担心的关系，但这方法非常明确、非常深刻地宣告：“不，这就是我们现在正在努力的方向，这就是我们想要成为的人。”另一种方法——如果视觉化和情绪板、愿景板不是你最喜欢的方法的话——是为你的新时代确定一个你真正想要体现的主题，你将用它来引领、激励、指导你在新季节中所做的一切。比如，当需要做出决定或者你面前有一个艰难的选择时，我希望你拥有那个单一的主题、那个能够果断为你做出选择的词。让我再解释一下这一点。对于这个新时代，你的主题可以是纪律。它可以是重塑、重生、激情、创造力、真实、探索、直觉、专注、勇气。
what this new era represents for you before it even emerges. And you've already done that in a way, by focusing on those questions that we were talking about before, you do already have an idea. But then you have to get it out of your mind into some physical form, either through action or through something like visualization. So some ways that people do this is through like vision boards, you know, spending an afternoon, really putting to page or to poster, what this next chapter looks like for you, you know, with pictures of destinations that you'll visit and accomplishments
我希望你选择其中一个或属于你自己的主题，这个主题将成为你在接下来六个月里旨在做的一切的核心。让我在这里用“重塑”这个主题来解释为什么这行得通。你知道，它非常适合这一集节目，但要体现重塑，实际上意味着以不同的方式做事，对吧？为新事物腾出空间，为那些你以前没有尝试过的事情腾出空间，
and the nature that you'll see, the mornings that you'll have, the hobbies that will relax you. You need to have an idea of what you're actually aiming for here. And visualization is extremely psychologically powerful. There was a recent study that said about, a quarter of successful entrepreneurs use vision boards or a similar process to map out change for themselves. And there was a 2019 study that also suggests that vision boards, as much as we sometimes think that they're silly, actually no, they almost double an individual's level of
也许是因为你害怕、尴尬、受制于他人的评判，但你无论如何都要去做。你正在迈入这个新时代。你在重塑自我。所以如果有人邀请你去一个你通常不会去的派对，而你还在犹豫不决、举棋不定时，你这里有一个简单的解决方案。
confidence in their ability to effectively execute actions necessary to achieve a desired outcome. and it really promotes people to seek out supportive resources and it keeps this vision of who they want to be who they're working towards very squarely in the front of their mind because life is full of distractions there are lots of things pulling us this way that way you know you're busy you know there's people's expectations there's money to worry about there's you know relationships to worry about but this method really squarely says very deeply says no this is what we're working towards right now this is who we want to be another way to do this if visualization and you know mood boards vision boards sorry aren't really your favorite method it's to identify a theme for your new error
什么决定最符合“重塑”这个主题？最符合的决定就是去参加这个派对。这就是你的行动指南。如果你，你知道，在出门时纠结穿不穿一件你可能永远不会穿的衣服，并且你在想：“也许我应该把它脱下来，我真的不知道。”嗯，你必须首先受“重塑”的指引。
that you really want to embody and that you will use to charge motivate direct everything that you're doing in this new season. As in, you know, when it's time to make a decision or you have a hard choice ahead of you, I want you to have that one theme, that one word that decisively chooses for you. Let me explain this a little bit more. So with this new error, your theme could be discipline. It could be reinvention, rebirth, passion, creativity, authenticity, exploration, intuition, focus, courage.
在接下来的六个月里，一切都要回归这个主题。它对你来说是一个非常简单的指南针、一个决策工具，就像是：“好吧，如果我面临两个选择，与我的主题最契合的那一个就是我必须做的，就是我需要去追求的。”这真的是一个非常强大的心理技巧。因为有时我们着手重塑生活时，你知道，你会试图做一个全面的大整顿，想要立刻同时改变所有事情。最终，你真正想要成为的那个版本的自己，在所有的混乱中有点迷失了。
I want you to choose one of those or one of your own, a theme that is going to sit at the core of everything you aim to do for the next six months. Let me use the theme of reinvention here to explain why this works. You know, it's very appropriate for this episode, but to embody reinvention, that really means doing things differently, right? Making space for what's new, making space for things that you haven't tried before,
当你把它简化，当你把它回归到一个且仅一个主题时，你就能更好地集中精力，而不会陷入混乱之中，也不会陷入转变往往带来的杂乱无章中。超越这种方法，现在让我们转向一些长期的活动，来刷新、重新激活你在二十岁的生命，特别是与设定目标有关的事项。现在，我要说一件可能会引起争议、可能会出乎意料的事情。但在我看来，设定目标是世界上最无聊的事情之一。这可能会让你感到惊讶，但我真的很难
maybe because you're scared, you're embarrassed, you're held back by the judgments of others, but you're going to do it anyways. You are stepping into this new area. You're reinventing yourself. So if someone invites you to a party that you'd normally not go to and you're kind of uming and a-ring about whether you want to go, you have an easy solution here.
去融入那些生活中每件事都有一百万个目标的人群中，因为对我来说这实在是太紧张、太有纪律性了。我天生的倾向是——过去和现在都是——通过直觉去感受事情，跟着感觉走，而不是制定什么两年计划、五年计划。你知道，我可以长时间为事情付出极大努力。但是，你知道，我并不是很热衷于每六个月重置一次目标、规划我想去的地方，并为了实现这一目标去做一些具体的事情。我慢慢开始摒弃那种哲学，你知道，我认为我之前被误导了。我以为设定目标必须是非常强烈的。而实际上，不，它不一定非得是那样的。它不需要让你变成一个
What decision would best align with that theme, reinvention? The decision that best aligns is to go to the party. That is your directive. If you're, you know, back and forthing over living the house in, I don't know, an outfit that you probably never wear. And you're like, maybe I should take this off. I don't really know. Well, you have to be guided by reinvention above all else.
极其自律的人。实际上，它真正关乎的是改变，对吧？而且，正如我们常说的，如果你不改变，什么都不会改变；同理，如果你无法想象它们改变，什么也不会改变，而这正是设定目标的核心所在。对自己说：这可以是不一样的，我生活的这一部分、我的日常、我的生活方式、我的工作可以是不一样的，我可以更快乐，我要相信自己，
Everything is coming back to this theme for the next six months. It is a very simple, you know, compass for you, a decision-making tool that's like, okay, if I'm faced with two choices, the one that best aligns with my theme is the one that I have to do, is the one that I need to pursue. this is just such a powerful, I think, mental trick. Because sometimes we like set out to reinvent our lives and like, you know, you kind of try and do a whole overhaul and you want to change everything right now at once. And eventually like this version of you that you're actually aiming for gets a little bit lost in all the chaos.
并且我相信我有能力做到这一点，有能力带来这种改变。我认为，与其有一个远在天边的大目标，我最近接触到了一个叫做“改变时间线”的概念。而改变时间线是另一种概念化目标或设定基准的方式，它没有那么强烈，更偏向日常，被分解成这些小块。你有一个一年目标、六个月目标、月度目标和每日目标，或者我们通常所说的微习惯——你每天做的事情，有望在最后积聚成巨大的胜利。然后你可以真正将这种“改变时间线”应用到你渴望的任何领域，任何需要重塑、需要刷新的领域。它可以是职业、友谊、
When you simplify it, when you bring it back to one theme and one theme only, you are just better able to truly focus and not get close. caught up in the clutter and not get caught up in the chaos that transformation often brings. Moving beyond this method, let's now turn to some longer-term activities for refreshing, recharging your life in your 20s, specifically to do with goal setting. Now, I'm going to say something that might be controversial, that might be unexpected. But goal setting to me is one of the most boring things to talk about in the world. And that might surprise you, but I really struggle.
健康、财务或者创造性的激情。比如，考虑改变你的健康状况。你知道，也许你的改变时间线将是：每天散步 30 分钟，然后你的一个月目标是每周去两次健身房。你的六个月目标是跑完 5 公里，一年目标是养成健身习惯并能够跑 10 公里。我认为与健身相关的目标非常容易纳入“改变时间线”中。但你可以看出这种方法如何真正让你将动力和可持续的习惯养成与长期规划结合起来。你知道，因为你的目标是沿着一段旅程而存在的，
to, you know, be around people who have a million goals for every single thing in their life because it just feels so intense and disciplined to me. And my natural inclination is and was to really feel my way through things and to like go with my gut rather than having like a two year, five year plan. You know, I could work very hard at things for a long period of time. But, you know, I wasn't really into resetting goals every six months and planning out where I wanted to be and doing distinct things to make that happen. I have slowly begun to retire that philosophy that, you know, I think I was misguided. I thought that goal setting had to be really intensive. Um, when actually, no, it doesn't have to be that way. It doesn't have to make you an
它们是沿着时间线排列的，而不仅仅是由一个起跑线、一个雄心勃勃的宏伟梦想和一个终点线组成——你知道，那种当你到达时会是什么样子的感觉，而中间却一片空白。我想这正是大多数新年决议经常失败的原因。俄亥俄大学曾做过一项民意调查，显示 23% 的人在 1 月 7 日结束前就会放弃他们的迎新决心，近 50% 的人在第二周就会放弃，因为我们低估了我们将要取得的进展。所以我们把目标定得太大，并且在过程中缺乏积极的强化，
ultra disciplined person. Actually, it's really about change, right? And, you know, as we always say, nothing changes if you don't and in a similar vein nothing changes if you can't imagine them changing and that is really what goal setting is all about saying to yourself this could be different this part of my life my routine my lifestyle my job could be different and I could be happier and I'm going to trust myself
因为我们只想着开头和结尾。而且为了实施那些重大且即时的改变，从心理和生理上讲，都是非常非常困难的。想要全线出击、直接改变关于你生活的一切，这非常困难。你需要通过一致性来建立那个基础，而不是靠着断断续续、随机爆发的努力去冲刺那些新的巅峰。
and I'm going to believe that I am capable of doing that of bringing about that change I think instead of having one big goal that is miles away, I was recently introduced to this concept called the timeline for change. And the timeline for change is another way of conceptualizing your goals or setting up benchmarks that is a bit less intensive and more daily and broken down into these small pieces. You have a one year goal, a six month goal, a monthly goal and a daily goal, or what we would. you know, typically call a micro habit, the thing that you do each day that hopefully builds to the big win at the end. You can really then apply this like timeline for change to whatever area you desire, whatever, whatever area needs reinvention needs a refresh. It could be career, friendship,
总而言之，我们的第三个建议是：通过让事情具有可操作性、让事情变得现实，并真正实施一个你既感到兴奋又切实可行的可持续的改变时间线，来为重塑自我腾出必要的空间。好了，我可爱的听众们，我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我想讨论更多关于那些更自发、更叛逆、也许能带来焕新感的改变路径，一个对重塑自我更具活力、更具朝气的视角。我们还有很多事情要聊。所以请留在我们身边。2%。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
health, finance is a creative passion. Think about, you know, transforming your health, for example. You know, perhaps your timeline for change would be to every day walk for things. 30 minutes and then your one month goal would be to go to the gym twice a week. Your six month goal is to run a 5k and by one year to have a gym routine and be able to run 10k. I think fitness related goals slot very easily into the timeline for change. But you can kind of see how this method really allows you to combine both momentum and sustainable habit building with that long-term planning. You know, because your goals are sitting along a journey.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析心理坚韧的科学。在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，体能和抗压能力。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后，
they're sitting along a timeline rather than just consisting of a start line, an ambitious, big dream, and a finish line, you know, a sense of what is going to be like when you get there, and, you know, nothing in between. And I think that is exactly why most New Year's resolutions often fail. You know, there was a poll done by the University of Ohio that showed 23% of people will quit their New Year's resolutions by the end of January 7th and almost 50% by the second week, because we underestimate how much progress we're going to make. So we think too big and we lack the positive reinforcement along the way
成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO. Persent。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩蠢游戏，赢蠢奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女孩。
because we're only thinking about the beginning and the end. And B, to enact those significant and immediate changes, you know, psychologically and physically speaking, it's very, very difficult. It's very difficult to just come in all guns blazing and change everything about your life. You need to build that foundation through consistency, not through new peaks with random, you know, dashes of effort.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的新一季中，哦天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我一定要做他最后一个目标。
So to summarize, our third tip, give yourself the necessary space for reinvention by making things actionable, by making things realistic, and really implementing a sustainable timeline for change that you are both excited about, but is also very, very doable. Okay, my lovely listeners, we are going to take a short break, but when we're back, I want to discuss some more of, you know, more of our spontaneous, rebellious, maybe refreshing paths for change, a more energetic, you know, perspective on reinvention. We have a lot more to talk about. So please stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness. fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the,
嗯，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈 80 年代的快克（毒品）。需要说明的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。
other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girl.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始发现其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以……谢谢你把那句话说完。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是最重要的一年之一。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed, I will be his last target.
对于美国历史上的黑人而言。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间时做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两种不同水平的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years.
加入我，Kear Gaines，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索 Learn the Hard Way，立即收听。在某个阶段，如果你想成长进入下一个人生阶段，你将不得不做一些真正让你感到害怕的或者你认为不可能的事情。长期的目标设定、拥有一个规划阶段、进行视觉化、明确你想要什么、为自己贴上这个新时代的标签是如此美妙。
for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
对于美国历史上的黑人来说。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back At It”。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师 Kear Games。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我说的是 Tripp Fontaine、Ryan Clark。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍然在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Steve Burns、Dustin Ross，因为你们觉得在人间做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. At some stage, you are going to have to do something that really scares you or that you didn't think was possible if you want to grow into your next phase. Long-term goal setting, having a planning phase, visualizing, articulating what you want, labeling this new error for yourself is so wonderful.
加入我和 Kear Gaines 的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开您免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hardway”，立即收听。在某个阶段，如果你想成长进入下一个阶段，你将不得不做一些真正让你害怕的事情，或者你认为不可能的事情。长远的目标设定、制定规划阶段、可视化、清晰表达你的想要什么、为自己标定这个新纪元，这一切都太棒了。
for. You know, by that stage, you really, you can't go wrong, but one of the easiest ways to almost guarantee transformation and to speed up your reinvention, your realignment is to take risks, big or small. Risk in my mind is like the fast forward button. There's less accuracy about where you're going to end up, right? Like, you're skipping through a movie, you want to get to the action quicker, but it means that you really propel yourself even faster into this new error. There is not a single person that you admire, that you respect. You idolize whether that is professionally or personally that has gotten to where they are without being a little bit daunted and unsure of whether they made the right decision.
所以，你知道，到了那个阶段，你真的，怎么都不会错。但几乎能保证蜕变、加速你的重塑和重新对齐的最简单方法之一，就是去冒险，无论大小。在我看来，冒险就像快进按钮。你对最终会去哪里没那么确定，对吧？就像你在快进一部电影，你想更快地看到精彩部分，但这确实意味着你以更快的速度把自己推进了这个新时代。没有哪个人是你钦佩、尊敬的，无论是职业上还是个人生活上，你所崇拜的那些人，他们在到达今天的地位时，能不感到有点畏惧，也不确定自己是否做出了正确的决定。
You know, actually for me, if you're questioning whether you've made the right decision, you are exactly in the place you need to be because those are the decisions that really contribute to growth. Easy decisions feel great because they don't require you to really question anything fundamental about yourself. But hard decisions, risks, that is where you really have to look in the mirror and question what do I actually want for my life. A lot of people don't do that.
你知道，其实对我来说，如果你在质疑自己是否做对了决定，那你正处于你需要呆的地方，因为正是这些决定真正促进了成长。轻松的决定感觉很好，因为它们不需要你去质疑关于你自己的任何根本问题。但艰难的决定、冒险，才是你真正需要照镜子，质疑你到底想从生活中得到什么的时候。很多人并没有这样做。
Another way I think about it is, you know, how when we build muscle at the gym or when we're working out, what is actually happening are these micro tears. You know, things are ripping, space is being made, it's painful. But then those holes get filled with new mass and we grow. It's a strange analogy, I know, but it's how I think about risk. You know, a small tears that are sometimes sore, that are sometimes uncomfortable. I don't really know what you're doing. You know, you don't really know what you're doing, but it needs to happen in order to bring about strength.
我思考它的另一个方式是，你知道，就像我们在健身房练肌肉或锻炼时，实际发生的是这些微小的撕裂。你知道，组织在撕裂，空间被创造出来，这是痛苦的。但随后这些空隙被新的肌肉组织填满，我们便成长了。这是一个奇怪的比喻，我知道，但这就是我对冒险的看法。你知道，那些有时会痛、有时会不舒服的小撕裂。你其实不知道自己在做什么。你知道，你其实并不知道自己在做什么，但这必须发生，才能带来力量。
And psychologically, risk is scary naturally, right? because anything that's unfamiliar will cause our brain to have quite a natural hesitancy, because it is hesitant towards the unknown. But just because your mind says something is scary doesn't necessarily mean it should be avoided. Actually, it might mean the opposite. If you're going to do one thing to reinvent yourself during this decade, it's to take a risk that you've always wanted to, but never imagine that you could. And I'm going to give you like a rapid fire list as to why I believe this truly and deeply.
在心理学上，冒险自然是可怕的，对吧？因为任何不熟悉的事物都会让我们的大脑产生相当自然的犹豫，因为它对未知感到犹豫。但仅仅因为你的大脑说某事很可怕，并不一定意味着应该避开它。实际上，这可能意味着相反。如果你在这个十年里要做一件事来重塑自我，那就是去冒一个你一直想冒、但从没想过自己能做到的险。我要给你列一个连珠炮式的清单，说明为什么我深深地坚信这一点。
And I want you to seriously try and rebut my reasons with the reasons why you shouldn't. Number one, you will never have as few responsibilities as you do now. Number two, you are the youngest that you will ever be, probably with the least to lose. You will never have more time than you have right now. I also think that risks are an investment. They are not a cost. they will benefit your life and your foundations way more than the risks that you don't take and way more than playing it safe.
我想让你认真尝试反驳我的理由，并列出你不该去做的理由。第一，你永远不会像现在这样拥有这么少的责任。第二，你是你这辈子最年轻的时候，可能也是最输得起的。你永远不会拥有比现在更多的我也认为冒险是一项投资。它们不是一种成本。它们对你的生活和根基的好处，远大于你不去冒的险，也远大于墨守成规。
And finally, in a very similar vein, you are more likely to live with regret over the risks you didn't take over the ones that you did. And if you want some anecdotal primary evidence of this, ask your parents or your grandparents next time you see them what their biggest regrets are. And I would say 80% of the time your parents are going to say, oh, you know, the time I didn't travel, the time I was too scared to do that thing that I should have, the time that I didn't tell that person I loved them, the time that I said no to an opportunity that I really actually should have taken because of imposter syndrome. Regret often feeds off inaction rather than action. Here's the thing, reinventing yourself through risk doesn't have to be dramatic. Some of us get really paralyzed by this idea that to move forward, we have to do something we are deeply uncertain of.
最后，以非常相似的思路，比起你做过的冒险，你更有可能为没有去冒的险而感到遗憾。如果你想找一些轶事作为直接证据，下次见到父母或祖父母时，问问他们最大的遗憾是什么。我想80%的情况下，你的父母会说：“哦，你知道，我没有去旅游的那次，我太害怕而没做那件事的那次，我没有对那个人说我爱他的那次，因为冒名顶替综合症，我对一个其实真该接受的机会说‘不’的那次。”遗憾往往滋生于不作为，而不是行动。事情是这样的，通过冒险来重塑自我并不需要多么戏剧化。我们中的一些人被这样一种想法弄得不知所措：要前进，我们就必须做一些我们深感不确定的事情。
And normally this is the case if you're quite risk-averse, right? So in psychology and economics even, there are these different profiles of the types of people in their perspective on risk. There are risk-positive people, people who will put it all on the line very frequently without really considering the costs. There are risk-neutral people, people who are very practical, almost mathematical. about the costs and benefits of a risk. And then there are risk-averse individuals, those of us whose minds just naturally exaggerate the consequences and the costs of the risk
通常情况确实如此，如果你相当厌恶风险的话，对吧？所以在心理学甚至经济学中，对风险的视角有不同类型的人格画像。有风险积极型的人，他们会非常频繁地孤注一掷，而不大考虑成本。有风险中立型的人，他们非常务实，对风险的成本和收益几乎是用数学方式看待。然后是风险厌恶型的人，我们这些人，内心自然会夸大风险的后果和成本，
over the benefits to the point where the risk actually seems entirely ridiculous. You know, we are convinced that we should always play it safe. And if that is you, if the idea of moving to a new country knowing no one, quitting your job without anything lined up, if that is really, really scary, What I want you to adopt is this idea of micro risks, things that you can slowly incorporate
把它们看得远超收益，以至于风险本身看起来简直荒谬。你知道，我们坚信自己应该永远稳妥行事。如果这就是你，如果搬到一个谁也不认识的新国家、在没有找好下家的情况下辞职，如果这真的、真的很可怕，我希望你采纳的是微风险的概念，也就是你可以慢慢融入的事情，
to almost increase your tolerance for the uncertainty that comes along with these decisions. You can go on solo dates. You can go on micro adventures on the weekend, solo. You don't have to travel across the world. You can book an Airbnb for the weekend in the mountains near a national park, somewhere like an hour or two away. and just enjoy a new part of the world alone. My cousin Stella actually, she was just messaging me about her solo camping trip
以此来提高你对这些决定所带来的不确定性的耐受力。你可以去进行单人约会。你可以在周末进行微探险，一个人去。你不必环游世界。你可以在山里、离国家公园近的地方、大概一两个小时车程的地方租个Airbnb过周末，独自享受世界的一个新角落。事实上，我表妹斯特拉刚刚给我发信息，讲了她过去两三天独自去露营的经历。
that she's been on for the last two to three days. Literally, she's only like an hour or two from her home, but she's just having the most amazing time. And she's doing something that she may not normally do, and it's just completely expanded her perspective on her life. Like in the span of two days, just getting out of an old environment and into a new one. These are small but mighty choices.
说真的，她离家只有一两个小时的车程，但她度过了极其美妙的时光。她在做一些她平时可能不会做的事，这完全拓宽了她对生活的看法。就像在短短两天内，离开旧环境，进入新环境一样。这些都是微小但强有力的选择。
Some more examples, you know, share your passion, your art, your hobbies, your lifestyle online to a private audience. Ask new people to go for coffee, be spontaneous, do something different this weekend that's not your usual Sunday reset. Start putting $20 a week aside purely for a dream fund. Just take, you know, those first steps without worrying about them being perfect. And that might not sound like a risky thing to do for some people, but I think anything that goes against the habits, the systems, the routines that you have in place to keep you secure and safe that you are using as a crutch, anything that's like that, that is a risk. That is a risk that you are taking to go against what your natural, deeply ingrained
更多例子，你知道的，把你的热情、艺术、爱好、生活方式在私密受众面前分享到网上。邀请新朋友去喝咖啡，随性一点，这个周末做点不同于你惯常的周日重置的事情。每周开始存20美元，专门作为梦想基金。只需迈出那些第一步，而不必担心它们是否完美。对某些人来说，这听起来可能不像是冒险的事，但我认为，任何违背你习惯、系统、日常的事情——那些你用来保持安全稳妥、当作拐杖的事情——任何类似的事情，都是冒险。那是你为了违背自然、根深蒂固的
intuition is telling you to do. What I want you to remember is that you are in charge here of creating a reality. you love, creating a version of yourself that you love even more, sometimes that's going to take courage. The path to reinvention, I think, involves risk and it involves a little bit of fear. So my fifth and my final tip for you today is to stop asking yourself, what if, and instead replace that with what else, or my favorite, so what. Each of us again has an idea of our truer selves, the person that we would be if no one else was watching, if this magical switch was turned that suddenly met that you were free from other's opinions, if the only person we were focused on was ourselves.
直觉告诉你要做的事而冒的险。我想让你记住的是，你在这里负责创造一个你热爱的现实，创造一个你更热爱的自己，有时这需要勇气。我认为，重塑自我的道路涉及风险，也涉及一点恐惧。所以今天给你的第五个也是最后一个建议是：停止问自己“如果……怎么办”，而是用“还能怎样”来代替它，或者我最喜欢的“那又怎样”。我们每个人同样都有一个关于更真实自我的想法，如果我们没有人在看，如果这个神奇的开关被打开，突然意味着你摆脱了别人的看法，如果我们关注的唯一焦点是我们自己，我们会成为的那个人。
We all had this idea of who we would be in that situation. They're almost a fantasy. They're a character, you know, that we've created that we one day aspire to be, but we're not really, not really focused on that right now. Now, the things that are really maintaining that gap between who we are now and who we would really love to be is normally our fear of judgment, our fear of upsetting others and their expectations, our fear of embarrassment of being perceived, that's a huge one, and our fear of change. These fears are all maintained by these what-if disaster scenarios. If I start putting myself out there, if I start being loud about my hobbies, about my desires,
在这种情况下，我们所有人都有过关于自己会成为谁的想法。它们几乎是一种幻想。它们是你创造的一个角色，你渴望有一天能成为它，但我们现在并没有真正专注于此。现在，真正维系着“我们现在的样子”与“我们真正想成为的样子”之间差距的，通常是我们对评判的恐惧、对惹恼他人及其期望的恐惧、对被注意到的尴尬的恐惧（这是一个巨大的恐惧），以及对改变的恐惧。这些恐惧全都是靠那些“万一发生灾难”的假设来维持的。如果我开始展现自己，如果我开始大声谈论我的爱好、我的愿望，
if I start wearing what I want, if I start staying no to people, if I let myself be perceived as my truest, authentic self, what if no one likes this version of me? What if I'm ostracized? What if I tell someone about my dreams and I fail? What if people don't like this reinvented version of me? I lose all my friends and I end up alone. You know, what if, what if?
如果我开始穿我想穿的衣服，如果我开始对别人说不，如果我让自己以最真实、最纯粹的自我被别人看到，要是没人喜欢这个版本的我怎么办？要是我被孤立了怎么办？要是我把自己的梦想告诉别人却失败了怎么办？要是人们不喜欢这个重塑后的我怎么办？我失去了所有的朋友，最后孤身一人。你知道，万一呢，万一呢？
not only are most of these very social fears, meaning that we are being guided more so by the potential opinions of others rather than the reality that we are the only one who has to experience and enjoy our lives, but they are also just anxious thoughts, they are not predictions, they most likely not come true. If you've listened to our most recent episode on anxiety, you'll know that the easiest way to distinguish between an anxious thought and a thought that you should pay attention to is if those thoughts begin with a what if. Here's how we counteract that. We counteract it with what else or so what statements. So let's take this statement. What if I tell everyone about my dreams and I fail? You know, I'll be so embarrassed. I better play it safe. That's one way of thinking
这些不仅大多是非常社交层面的恐惧，这意味着我们更多地受制于他人潜在的看法，而不是这样一个现实：我们才是唯一必须体验和享受自己生活的人；而且它们也只是焦虑的想法，并非预测，它们极有可能是不会成真的。如果你听了我们最近关于焦虑的那期节目，你就会知道，区分焦虑的想法和你应该关注的想法的最简单方法，就是看这些想法是否以“如果……怎么办”开头。我们是这样来对抗这种情绪的。我们用“还能怎样”或“那又怎样”的说法来对抗它。所以让我们拿这句话来说。如果我把自己的梦想告诉所有人然后失败了怎么办？你知道的，我会觉得好尴尬。我还是稳妥点好。这是一种思考方式，
and it is a naturally limited way of thinking, but consider now ending that statement with so what. Okay, maybe I'll be embarrassed. So what? What is the worst case scenario? I'm embarrassed, it's uncomfortable, so what? So people might not like me? So what?
这是一种天生局限的思考方式，但现在试着用“那又怎样”来结束这句话。好吧，也许我会尴尬。那又怎样？最坏的情况是什么？我很尴尬，这很不舒服，那又怎样？所以人们可能不喜欢我？那又怎样？
And then, again, keep going, keep going with the so what's until you get to the final conclusion of your fear. And you realize that actually there is not much harm that embarrassment can really. really do. This method is about taking an anxious, fear-based thought and actually interrogating it, because so often we're too scared to even think about our anxious thoughts that we just let them get away with lying to us. But when we say, so what? Our anxiety kind of is like, oh, well, you've never questioned me before, so I don't really know. I don't really know what's going to happen. And that's
然后，再次继续，不断地用“那又怎样”追问，直到你得出恐惧的最终结论。你会发现，实际上尴尬并不能造成多大的、真正的伤害。这种方法是把一个基于焦虑和恐惧的想法拿出来进行审问，因为通常我们太害怕甚至去思考我们的焦虑想法，以至于我们任由它们用谎言糊弄我们。但当我们说“那又怎样”时，我们的焦虑有点像是：哦，好吧，你以前从未质疑过我，所以我真的不知道。我真的不知道会发生什么。就在那时，
when I think we see things more clearly. We see things for what they really are. which is not as big in reality as they are in our minds. The other option is to say, well, what else? What if people don't like this new version of me? Okay, that's one unlikely option, but what else? Let's expand that disaster scenario and go in search of some other alternatives. You know, what if I actually attract people who are really aligned with who I truly am? What if I suddenly meet the greatest friends I'll ever have?
我认为我们能把事情看得更清楚。我们看清了事物的真实面目，它们在现实中并不像在我们脑海中那样巨大。另一个选择是说，嗯，还能怎样？如果人们不喜欢这个新版本的我怎么办？好吧，这是一个不太可能的选择，但还能怎样？让我们放大那个灾难情景，去寻找一些其他的替代方案。你知道，如果我实际上吸引了那些与我真实的自我真正契合的人呢？如果我突然遇到了我这辈子能拥有的最好的朋友呢？
what if I suddenly attract a love that I deserve? What if I completely level up every aspect of my life and I never look back? What if I am the happiest I have ever been? What else? Remember, the first thought that you have is probably not the most accurate. And you can grab onto that thought. You can let it control you. You can let it dominate your choices.
如果我突然吸引到我应得的爱情呢？如果我彻底将生活的所有方面都提升到一个新水平，并且绝不回头呢？如果我是我有生以来最快乐的时候呢？还能怎样？记住，你的第一个想法可能不是最准确的。你可以抓住那个想法。你可以让它控制你。你可以让它主宰你的选择。
But you also have this extreme power and ability. to be whoever you want to be if you just zoom out and question your fear, replacing that what if with what else or so what? During this, you know, brief time that we have on earth, you deserve, at the bare minimum, to actually be yourself. Sometimes we do find ourselves in a loop of not knowing who we are, not liking who we are either, not liking our lives because of boredom, stagnation, you know, isolation. The longer you spend as this version of you, you will become quite used to the discomfort
但你同时也拥有这种极大的力量和能力，只要你拉远视角、质疑恐惧，用“还能怎样”或“那又怎样”取代那个“如果怎么办”，你就能成为你想成为的任何人。在我们在这个地球上度过的这（你知道的）短暂时间里，你至少应该能够真正做自己。有时我们确实会陷入这样一种循环：不知道自己是谁，也不喜欢自己是谁，由于无聊、停滞不前、孤立无援而不喜欢自己的生活。你以这个版本的自己度过的时间越长，你就会对这种不适感习以为常，
and you will no longer feel like you have to outgrow that shell. You'll just keep squeezing yourself back in, hiding away. And it becomes a lot easier to tolerate. I don't want that for you. To be honest, I don't want that for anyone. I don't want anyone to be 80 and think, what if I'd just done it a little bit bigger? What if I just had one six-month period?
你将不再觉得必须摆脱那个外壳。你只会继续把自己塞回去，躲藏起来。这变得更容易忍受了。我不想看到你这样。说实话，我不想看到任何人这样。我不希望任何人到了80岁时还在想：如果我当初动作再大一点会怎样？如果我哪怕有过短短六个月的
of reinvention because you have no idea what that could do for your life. You have no idea how much growth and new experiences you could have in six months. How many weeks is that? Oh my God, I've got to do quick maths, like 24 weeks. I could be completely wrong. Please correct me. 24 weeks, right? Yeah. You could just be a completely new person. That's 24 weeks of time for you to reinvent, transform, invest in yourself. This is an investment. I really want you to take your dream seriously, take responsibility for your happiness, take responsibility for evolving into the most authentic version of yourself, even if that requires a bit of a painful metamorphosis. So I really hope that you got something from this episode. I hope that you can
重塑期会怎样？因为你根本不知道那会对你的生活产生什么影响。你根本不知道在六个月内你能获得多少成长和新体验。那是多少个星期？天哪，我得快速算一下，大概24周吧。我可能完全算错了。请纠正我。24周，对吧？是的。你可能就会变成一个全新的人。那是24周的时间，供你重塑、蜕变、投资自己。这是一笔投资。我真的希望你认真对待你的梦想，为你的幸福负责，为演变成最真实的自己负责，即使这需要一点痛苦的蜕变。所以我真的很希望你从这期节目中有所收获。我希望你能
take on board this advice. You know, you can cherry pick it as. you wish. If some things you already do, some things you don't, whatever you need, take what you need. That's what we always say at the end of these episodes. And feel free to send it to someone else who you think might benefit, who you think might enjoy what we've been talking about. As always, five-star reviews are also appreciated, as is a follow, either on Spotify or Apple Podcasts or on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you enjoyed this episode or you have a future episode that you would like to suggest anything to do with psychology, self-help, wellness in our 20s, mental health in our 20s, I would love to hear from you.
采纳这个建议。你知道的，你可以按需挑选。如果有些事情你已经在做了，有些还没做，无论你需要什么，拿走你需要的。这就是我们在这些节目结束时常说的话。欢迎把它分享给你认为可能会受益、可能会喜欢我们所谈论内容的人。一如既往，也非常感谢五星好评，无论是在Spotify、Apple Podcasts还是在Instagram的That Psychology Podcast上关注我们。如果你喜欢这期节目，或者你有未来想建议的节目主题——任何与20世纪的心理学、自助、健康、心理健康相关的内容，我都非常乐意倾听。
A final tidbit, we do have an event, a friendship event in Melbourne coming up on the 10th of October. I thought I would sneak that in here. So if you're a Melbourne-based listener and you want to make some like-minded friends, you want to meet me. I think we have a few tickets left on Eventbrite. You can go to our Instagram and there will be a link in our website. bio. I'm really excited to meet you guys. So let me know if I'm going to see you there.
最后提个小消息，我们在10月10日于墨尔本有一个活动，一个友谊活动即将举行。我想在这里偷偷塞进这个消息。所以，如果你是墨尔本的听众，想结交一些志同道合的朋友，想见见我。我想我们在Eventbrite上还剩几张票。你可以去我们的Instagram，个人简介里会有一个链接。我真的很兴奋能见到大家。所以让我知道我是不是能在那里见到你们。
If you'll be there, we'll be doing heaps of other events in Sydney, Brisbane, in Perth, I believe, and then also in the UK and later next year in the US. So cannot wait to meet you all. Until next time, stay safe, stay kind. Please be gentle with yourselves. You deserve a gentle life and gentle thoughts. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled,
如果你会去的话，我们在悉尼、布里斯班、珀斯（我想是的）还会举办一大堆其他活动，然后还会在英国以及明年晚些时候在美国举办。所以迫不及待地想见到你们所有人。下次见之前，保重，保持善良。请对你们自己温柔一点。你值得拥有温柔的生活和温柔的想法。我们很快、很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人的身份迎来蜕变。
healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down,
收听《2%》。即数字“2%”，可在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难一课》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方真正说起来都不太安全，但你是在与一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。在AHA电台应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格 Greg，一个同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。